as bitcoin's price continues to fall
there's a lot of people asking what are
the smart money doing what are the
institutions doing anthony scaramucci
the founder of skybridge he was on cnbc
this morning and he described it as
there's been a flight to quality
everyone is running to bitcoin and
they're running away from all the
altcoins and of course anthony said
they're buying bitcoin and ethereum
right now here's what anthony said on
television this morning it kind of feels
like we are i don't know if we're doing
a full round trip but
we're getting close you and i both know
interest rates going up
one to two percent rise in interest
rates easily take 10 to 15 out of the
market andrew so
uh everything's being impacted but
watching you guys this morning it makes
me think of march of 2000 unfortunately
i'm old enough to remember that where
internet stacks were cratering many of
the web one
stories went to zero and then of course
there were a few
uh gems things like amazon that went on
to do very well and i i am encouraged by
the fact that bitcoin is above 50 of the
overall crypto market gap right now uh
which is again another sign that there's
a flight to quality there now of course
celsius is putting pressure on it uh the
same way that the luna terror situation
put pressure on it about six weeks ago
so uh we're in a bloodbath uh this is my
eighth bear market i expect to survive
this one as well
but i think it just cautioned people to
stay unlevered
but keep to your long-term investment
discipline everybody has a long-term
perspective until they have short-term
losses andrew
and then they start to set their hair on
fire run around in a circle i would
recommend people just stay disciplined
uh and like joe don't look at your 401k
state now that's a great way to actually
look at even though price is going down
much of the smart money a lot of
institutional investors the further that
the price falls and the more conviction
they have in that long-term value of an
asset the more attractive it becomes
this doesn't mean that every single
institutional investor is buying right
now doesn't mean that all the smart
money agrees but what it does mean is
that one of the most outspoken
proponents of bitcoin anthony and
skybridge they're out there saying we're
buying and we like the long-term
prospects of this asset it's important
to always understand what smart money
and institutional investors are doing
they're one major player in the market
but you still have to go and do your own
fundamental research and understand
exactly what the asset is what your
investment strategy is and if this is
something to put in your portfolio
obviously anthony's done that work and
he thinks bitcoin is something he wants
to hold for a very long time hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time